早速話に入りますけど
今日は 無我の
この前の話の続きで
2番目なんです
前回の話は 少々わかりにくかったかもしれません
それは ちょっと順番の違いなんです
この話の 計画を立てると 一般的に考えて
まず 「無我って何ですか？」とかね
そういう紹介とか そういうことをして
それから 仏教の無我の話という風に やりますけどね
やっぱり 一般的に考えて 話の計画を立てると
仏教の無我は わからなくなっちゃうんです
で 逆にしたならば
「仏教で言っている無我は 何ですか？」 とした方が わかりやすかったかもしれません
今日は 仏教における 無我のお話ですから
なんとなく わかるだろうと思います
それから どう見ても 無我を理解することだというのは
本当は 仏教でいう 覚ることなんです
無我を知ることと同時に
我々の心にある 一切の悩み苦しみは
全部 消えてしまうんです
ですから 「無我」は 一種の体験であります
理解ではないんです
で 理解するものは 無我についてのものであって
また それも一種の 我的な考え方なんですね
そういう ちょっと 難しいところはあるんです
で 前の話の続きですから
前回 いらっしゃらなかった方々は わからないと思うかもしれません
だから一応 今日のお話は 今日の話でまとめるようにしゃべります
ですから 前回の話を聞かなくても
今日の話だけでも 理解できると思います
前の続きとしては お話はいたしません
で 我々がよく知っている 初期仏教の
キーワードは 3つあります
私たちは それをよく知っているんです
それは無常 苦 無我という 3つの言葉なんですね
パーリ語で anicca(アニッチャ) dukkha(ドゥッカ) anatta(アナッタ) と言うんですね
anattaよりは anattā(アナッター) でいいと思います
日本語で言えば「無常」
「苦」苦しみの「苦」と
「無我」ですね
代わりますか？お願いします
一応 日本語の
決まってる 日本語の言葉は
この「無常 苦 無我」と
で 私はいつでも言うのは
ただ言葉を見ただけで 「あ わかったぞ」という気持ちだけだったら
もう 何もわからなくなるんです
何でも 初めて聞くようなつもりで
チャレンジ精神で聞かなきゃ
物事は わからないんですね
私たちは 言葉によって 確実に騙されているんです
それは どういうわけかというと
我々は 言葉っていうのは
もう 2、3歳になると ほとんど勉強して終わっているんです
その時の意味で
我々の人生を 全部 理解しようとすると
それは 正しいとは 言いにくいんです
そこで問題は 何か言葉を言った途端
その小さな子は「あ わかったよ」と なっちゃうんですね
それから 少々 新しい言葉を付け加えていますが
やっぱり 基本的なことは全部
３歳ぐらいになっちゃうと
もう できているんですね
そういうわけで 本当に 新しい智慧が欲しいんだと
新しいものを発見したいという人が
やっぱり いつでも この言葉について 気をつけなくちゃいけない
どういうことかというと やっぱり
「あ 知ってるんだ」 という気持ちになっちゃうんですね
これは 私にも 学生の頃は よく注意されたことなんですね
仏教の勉強を始めたら
まず 先生方に言われたのは
「あなた方は」
まぁ 教室は大きかったんだから
「よく仏教の言葉とかね」
「小さい時から聞いて よく知ってるだろうと思っているんだけどね」
「それは全部 きれいさっぱり忘れなさい」と
「全く初めて聞くんだ」と
この この言葉 「無常」という言葉であろうが
「無我 」という言葉であろうが
全く初めて聞く
話しだと
そういう気持ちで 一切の固定概念を置いておいて 聞かなきゃ
立派な研究者には なれません と
単なる 固定概念でやらされていて
もう 何の新しいことも 発見できなくなりますから
「固定概念を全部捨てなさい」と言われてから 授業を始めたんですね
ですから 考えれば やっぱりそれはその通りで
違うことを言われると
気持ち悪くなっちゃうというか
怒るというか 腹が立ったりすることは あるんですね
そうすると やっぱりどういうわけかというと
自分たちが思っている考え方と
その同じ言葉をもって
向こう側が言うことが 違う場合は
やっぱり 気持ちは良くないんです
それで怒ったり 「あんた 何言ってるんですか？」と批判したりはする
そういう精神的なトラブルを 起こしちゃうんですね
だから 知識を求めている人
知恵を求める人が 自分 すでに持っている考え方に どう攻撃されても
何のことなく 「向こう側が 何を言ってるんですか？」ということで
それを 理解しようとする
どうせ 新しい考え方を聞くと
我々の今 すでに持っている 固定概念は 壊れるはずなんです
もし 固定概念が壊れなかったら
その人は 何も言ってないんです
ただ言葉で 美しい言葉で 遊んだだけになっちゃうんです
「自分が 自分の考え方が 変わってない」と言った人は 何も言ったことにはならない
特に この世の中で 人気のある話しというものが ありますね
なんで 人気があるかというと
話を聞く方々は 「その通りや」と
「私もそう思っていたんだ」と
そういう気持ちで聞くと
みんな 「すごくいい話しだ」と言うんです
「その通りや 私もそういうふうに思っていたんだ」と
「私も同じ意見だ」というふうに
ものすごい 抜群に共感できて
笑って楽しくて 話が終わったということは
「すべて無駄話でした」ということなんです
すべて無駄話でしたと
漫才と同じで
ですから 智慧を求めている人っていうのは
かなり 心の中で いろんな葛藤やら 混乱やら出てきたりして
それを いろいろ解決しながら 自分が成長していくんですね
ですから 新しい知識 新しい智慧
新しい理解を得るということは
ちょっと 苦しい仕事なんです
おだててもらいたいという場合は
その人は 何の知識 智慧は得られないんです
で 攻撃というか 「ショック」を 受ける可能性はいくらでもあります
そういうわけで 「無常」「空」「無我」とか
言葉を聞いた途端 「あ わかったよ」ということだったら
まぁ ちょっと困るんですね
「わかったよ」ではなくて
「無常ってなんですか？」と 新しく考えなくちゃいけないんですね
そこで これは 今日 説明する必要はないんですけど
ずっと しゃべってるんだから そのポイントについては
一応 今日のテーマに 必要なところだけ 説明します
で anicca 無常というのは
すべての現象 自分と他ですね
一切の現象を観察したところで
一切の現象について 何か ひとことで言える何かはあるかと
全部まとめて
一切の現象は どういうものかと言うと
お釈迦様が言っているのは
「無常ということは 言えるんだ」と
そういうわけで それに真理と言うんです
だから どんな人が どんな現象を確かめてみても
そこに無常ということは あるんです
だから すべてのものに 共通しているものだから 真理と言うんです
で 無常の説明は かえって難しいかもしれませんけど
私は その話になると いろいろ説明しますけどね
それは 物事は現象として 一時的に現れるものであって 変化していく
変化しないものは 何ひとつもないと
変化すること自体が 存在であると
「ものがある」という言葉が正しければ
「ものが変化している」という意味なんです
そこで 言葉に引っかかる人々が 「ある」という言葉に 引っかかっちゃうんです
あるんだから あるんじゃないかと
で よく考えると 「ある」ということは 「変化していく」ということで
「今ある」ということは 次の瞬間に その状態ではないんですね
それはわかります と思います
ですから 一切 私の体と 外の世界と 他の生命と
みんな ひとつのダイナミズムで ずっと変化している
変わって 変わっていく
その「変わること」に 「存在」と
一般的な人々の言葉を借りて 言えるんです
あるいは もっと具体的な例に行きましょう
光があると 蛍光灯は光っていると
そこで 「ある」という言葉に なるんですね
蛍光灯は光っている そこにそれは あるんでしょうし
でも そこは無常でなければ
その現象
「蛍光灯が光っている」という現象は 成り立たないんですね
そこで「あ わかった この蛍光灯のランプだけは 変化しているんだ」と
それは違います
なんで蛍光灯に付いている 他の部分は変化しないんですか？
それも 変化しているんです
そうでなきゃ 「ある」わけじゃないんです
「私がいる」という場合も
この体が変化してなきゃ 「いる」ということは言えません
ですから 厳密に理解してほしいのは
「世の中で いろんな人が存在しているんだ」
「あるんだ 実体があるんだ」
「何か 魂 霊魂 種みたいなもの」
「変化しないものは あるんだ」と言っても
それは言葉の誤りであって
言葉に 引っかかっているのであって
彼らは ちゃんと言語学を勉強していないというか
理解していないというだけであって
「ある」という言葉は成り立たない
本当は
論理的には
成り立つのは 「変化しているんだ」
「変わっていくんだ」ということなんです
人が変わっていないと
「ここに人がいる」という 仮の言葉は使えません
だから「いる」「いない」というのは
二元的な論理で 西洋的な
理解しやすいんですね
「ここに人がいる」 あるいは「ない」と
「どっちですか？」と
イエスとノーで
二元論ですか？
その二元論というのは
ヨーロッパの論理学は 二元論で成り立っているんですね
インドは 四元論になっているし
仏教は その四元論も否定することを
否定ではなくて 「成り立たない」と
ということで 仏教の論理があるんですね
「成り立たない」というところで
大変 難しくなってしまいます
そこら辺を 勉強したい方々がいるならば
ナーガルジュナさんのテキストを
いろいろ解釈もつけて いっぱいありますので 読んでみたら
この 四元論をね
「どのように成り立たないことを説明しているか 」を
明確に説明しているんです
そこでこの二元論で
「ここに人がいる」あるいは「ない」
そういうふうに 考える場合は
それは 便利な言葉の 便利な使い方であって
で 我々から 仏教の立場から見れば
そんなに 確かな意味があるわけじゃないんです
「人がある」ということ自体は
「そこに人がいない」ということですよと
それは はっきりと 金剛般若経ですか？
Vajracchedikā Prajñāpāramitā という大乗経典があります
そこで そういう項目だけ ザーッと並んで 言ってるんです
「ここに仏がいる」ということは 「ここに仏がいないことや」と
「菩薩は一切衆生を救済するんだ」ということは 「菩薩は一切衆生を救済しないということや」と
そうすると 「この人々は 何言ってるんですか？」と
「なんか わかりません」と 思うかもしれませんけど
すごい 簡単単純な 論理を言ってるんです
「ここに人がいる」ということは
そこで 今 瞬間いた人は
次の瞬間に 変わらなきゃ
だから 人がどこにいるんですかね？
「私はいる」という人が すぐ変わっていっちゃったんだから
見た光が 瞬間に消えて 違う光ですからね
「光がある」といっても
その見た瞬間の光が もう消えているんだから 違う光なんです
ですから 「ある」ということは 「ない」ということですよと
だから結局 仏教は こういう一般の人々が使っている
この単純な言葉で 遊んでいるんですね
言葉には 引っかかるなと思おうが
何の意味もないんだと 言葉の中には
「あんた ここに人があると言っても それ 大嘘だよ」と
本当に言葉に引っかかって 「ある」と思っちゃうんです
あれは大嘘であって 変化するんだから
言葉を借りて
世俗的に
一般的な言葉で
「ある」と言えるだけのことで 「実際はない」ということですよと
そういうのは 無常の考え方なんですね
じゃあ そんな風にしゃべると
また 仏教は ちょっとこの 論理学者やら言語学者やら
そういう哲学者の世界になってしまうんですね
でも お釈迦様は そういう風に いちいち訳も分からない
この人間 頭狂っちゃうような
「あるっていうことは ないということだよ」とかね
「あなたは 徳を積む ということは」
「あなたは 何の徳も積んでいないことや」とか
そんなことを お釈迦様は言えません
それは前に言った Vajracchedikā Prajñāpāramitā Sūtra という金剛般若経というのは
お釈迦様の教えではないんですね
それは 大乗経典で
随分 後で 遊びで書いた経典だろうと思います
ちょっと 遊んでやろうではないかと
そこで 「お釈迦様は どのように 無常のことをしゃべりますか？」というと
「もう 何でもいいんだから 見てみなさい」と
物事を 我々は 自分で理解できる立場で見たらいいんです
日常茶飯事のことを 例えば 「ご飯を見ました」と
「じゃあ ご飯は ずっと その通りに あるんですか？」と
「いえ その通りにいません」
食べられて 消えるか
そのまま放っておけば 腐って
いろいろ ウジ虫が出てきたりとかね
あるいは 土に戻るかと
止まっていないんですね
自分の形が変化して 全く別質なものに 変わるんですね
そこで 我々はご飯を持ってきて
それを ちょっと土と混ぜて
もう 土に戻るということで
置いておけば それは 肥料になっちゃうんですね
じゃあ 肥料とご飯は 全く同じものですかね？
全く 働きも 機能も 全部違うでしょうに
ご飯は 人間にも 動物にも食べられますが
肥料は 植物の栄養にしか ならないんですね
ですから 物事っていうのは そうやって 本質的に変化していくんです
変化しちゃったら 「あれ これはもともと どんなものでしたか？」とわからないんです
この前 私は同じ説明をしましたけど
今 私はしゃべってるっていうのは 前 食べたご飯なんですけど
そのエネルギーを 出してますけど
これは おにぎりか パンか どっちかと言えますかね？
今しゃべってる言葉のエネルギーは
この音は
これは もう何といいますか
梅干しの匂いがするんだから 梅干しだと
魚の匂いがするんだから これは おそらく 何かの焼き魚のエネルギーだと言えますかね？
まるっきり 言えるどころか
さっぱり 何かわからない
ただ簡単に言えるのは
「ご飯食べただろう」と
それぐらいのことなんです
それぐらい
跡形もなく 変化するんです
物事は
ですから それは我々の日常経験で
わかるもので
産んだ母親の子供が 例えば 1〜2歳で 取り上げられちゃって
それで 10〜15年経って見たら わからないでしょうに
跡形もなく 変化しているんです
そういう風に ものすごい
この もう 大胆的に 変化していくんです
で 私たちは 花というものと
その花を作ってくれる植物というのは どれほど違うかというと
みんな 好きな桜の花とか あるでしょう
桜の花と 桜の木と 比べちゃうと
何かありますか？ 似ているもの
何もないでしょう
花には かすかに香りがあるんだけど 木には全然ない
花が こんな小さくて
木は すごい大きくてとかね
指ででも つぶれちゃうし
桜の木はもう 自分も潰れるかもしれません
全く別質なものを 作っちゃうんです
そういう すべてのもの 何を見ても
「ある」と思うものは 全部無常なんです
ないものには 無常は関係ないんです
それに 仏教では すごい有名な例えありまして
この 「空華」（くうげ）という言葉がありますね
禅でも使ってますけど
「空の華」という漢字を 書くんですけどね
空と華と書いてね
「空に咲いた華」というのは ありえないことなんですね
そこは 存在しないんだから
そこには 無常という関係は ないんですね
例えば ウサギの角
いくらでも言えます
馬の翼は どうですか？とかね
亀の毛とかね そういう使ってる
伝統的に使っている 例えなんですね
亀さんの毛について しゃべってるんだと
そんなものは 存在しないんですね
馬の翼と言えば
だから 存在しないんだから
そちらについては 無常か無常でないか とかね
そんな もう 関係ない話
ただ人間が 言葉をふたつ つなげただけ
「亀の毛」といえば 「亀」と「毛」という言葉を つなげただけのことで
実在しない
でも 「実在する」「ある」と言うならば
すなわち「無常」であって すなわち「ない」ということなんです
そこで お釈迦様は そういうふうに 世の中を見てね
「まぁ 見たらどうですかね」とかね
「見たら変わるでしょ なんでも かんでも」
というふうなことで 一般の人に 理解できるように
「まぁ そうやって あなたが見るものも 聞くものも」
「あなた自身も あなたのお友達やら 親戚やら 子供たちやらね」
「みんな もう変わって 変わって」
「消えて 消えていくんだ」と
言葉を使うと ちょっと実体的な気持ちが 入っちゃいますけどね
「私が変わります」と言ったら なんか 私がいるような感じがしますから
そこは ややこしいところで
言葉を使わなきゃ しゃべれませんからね
そこら辺 ちょっと気をつけると
まぁ 無常はわかるんですね
そこで 私は 今日 言いたいのは
「無常」は 人間の 日常の経験なんですね
だから日常に 我々には 毎日経験できる
体験できる 味わう真理
Experience (エクスペリエンス)ですね
人間の経験から見れば
すべての現象は 無常である
ですから それには証明は要りません
人が 私を殴って 痛がったと
で 私には 「自分が痛い」ことに 証明は必要ですかね？
要りません 痛いこと自体は 証明なんです
ですから 無常であることには 特別に証明は要りません
わからないもの 経験できないものには 証明は必要なんです
遺体は見つからない場合は
その人が 死んでいるだろう ということには
ありとあらゆる 証明を出さなくちゃいけない
遺体が見つかったら もう
「こういうわけで この人は死んでるんですよ」と 言う必要はないんです
「もう 死んでるんですよ」と
ですから
経験ですから
「それには 証明は要りません」とだけ 覚えておいてください
「一切は無常である じゃあ証明してください」とは バカらしいです
人が「いえ 無常ではありません」と言ったら
「証明出してくれ」と言った方が 正しいんです
「理由を言ってください」と
それなのに
一切は無常であることには 証明は要りませんのに
お釈迦様は きちんと 「なぜ無常か」を説明しているんです
それは 仏教における因縁論の話なんです
いわゆる 物事には実体がなくて
一時的に
組み立てられて 現れるものや と
そこでキリがない
あるものを 我々は作ったとする
それは 一時的に 例えば ここに袋がありますから
袋は 作ったものだから 永遠じゃない 変化していく
じゃあ 袋を作った部品が永遠かというと
それも できたものだから それも変化する
じゃあ そのできたものは またできたものだから
そうやって キリがなく
もう 全部 できているもの
作られているもの
組み立てられているもので
saṅkhāra (サンカーラ) という言葉を使っているんですね
そこで 何で組み立てるか
どういうことか とかね
そこら辺は 因縁論の中で 明確に説明しています
それで 私は哲学的な言葉を借りて 言うと
これは empirical truth (エンピリカル トゥルース)というか
人間の経験から味わう 経験する事実ですね
ですから 「これ わからない」と言うと
なんか ちょっと おかしいと
「無常はわかりません」と
「無常じゃない」というならば
それ自体が おかしいんであって
ほんのちょっと 目を開けたら 無常であることは見えるんですね
次に
無常だから 無常たるものに
もうひとつ お釈迦様が 言葉を使っちゃいます
「dukkha (ドゥッカ) だよ」
そこで 漢字の「苦」では 我々は困りますけど
困ってもしょうがない パーリ語でも dukkha と書いてますから
「苦しみ」という意味が入っているんです
ですから 無常が故にだから 結局 言葉としてはイコールなんです
言葉としては
dukkha というのは
「だからもう 虚しいんだよ」と
「何も 味がないでしょう」と
例えば 花を見て 「あぁ すごい綺麗だ 私は これ欲しいんだ」と
「じゃあ 持っていきます」と
そうやって 囚われて 持っていっても  「無常だからね あんた苦しみだけだよ」と
これが 枯れてしまったら 悲しいでしょうに
まぁ 花は無常ということは わかってるんだから
それほど悲しくないんだけど
せっかく 大事な花を持ってきて
満員電車に乗ったところで 潰れたら 腹が立つでしょうに
あれ 何ですかというと 無常は認めていない
これは家に持っていって
植えたところで 1週間ぐらい見て 楽しんだところで
じわじわと枯れるだろうと 自分で計画を立てているんです
電車で潰れるだろう ということはないんです
「永遠だよ」と そこまでは
だから 無常は わかってない瞬間で
苦しみ 悩み 嫌な気持ちが 生まれてくる 腹が立つ
ですから  無常
それから一切のものについて
そうでなくては 何を理解するかといえば
「じゃあ 苦だ と理解してみなさい」と
「苦しみだ」と
「どんなものからも出てくる味わいは 苦しみではないか」と
で 苦には いろいろ
dukkha には いろいろ意味がありまして
「空しい 」「不安」「不完全」という 3つの意味があるんです
dukkha のことは そこら辺で 置いておいて
これは 人間の経験ですね
dukkha っていうのは価値なんですね
じゃあ「ここに人がいる」とは
「ここに人がいない」ということ
それで 評価するならば
価値判断するならば 「dukkha だよ」と
いわゆる まぁ こちらは哲学的に言えば
empirical facts (エンピリカルファクツ) というか
「経験できるところは こういうことや」と
こちらは なんとなく 道徳的でもない
倫理的でもないんだけど
なんとなく 価値判断を入れたければ
「大事なもの」とは 言えなくなっちゃうんですね
「あ すごい大事なものや」とは 言えないんですね
消えてしまいますから
もう二度と 戻りませんから
「あの消えた瞬間は 私にとって 一番大事な瞬間だから 持っていきます」と言っても 持っていけませんね
だから 「光はすごく大事なものだ」と言っても
それは ずっと 消えて 消えて 消えて いくんだから つかめません
これは もっとわかりやすい例で言えば 何て言いますか？
えーと 虹みたいなもんなんで
虹は 遠くから見れば綺麗ですけど じゃあ 触ってみてください
虹は 無常でなければ存在しないし
触って 持っていくことはできないし
捕まえて持っていくことは
だから ご自分たちで持っている 宝石やら アクセサリーみたいに
「あ これは私の大事な 大変高価な宝物や」
「だから 金庫に入れておきますよ」とかね
そういうふうに 価値を入れられますか？と 物事に
価値を入れられないんですね
だから「価値はない」と
価値はないは 「虚しい」ということで
価値判断との立場から dukkha と言うんです
そこで 一切現象は 変化することは 経験できる
「経験できるものには 少々価値判断を入れてみよう」と言うたら
「dukkhaだよ 苦しみだよ 虚しいよ」と
次に 我々のテーマの「無我」という言葉 入っちゃうんです
じゃぁ 「哲学的にというか もっと知恵を使って」
「何か言えることはありますか？」と言うと
「無我ですよ 実体はないんだ」と
ということで
ですから 「無我」っていうのは 日常茶飯事の経験ではないんですね
日常茶飯事の経験は 「無常」なんです
それから もうちょっと知恵を働かせちゃうと
「やっぱり 苦だよ」とわかります
さらに知恵を働かせちゃうと
「やっぱり何もないんだ 本当は」と
「実体がないんだ」と わかるんですね
それで「ある」ということは 無常であって
「あるが故にない」 っていうことは 無我なんです
だから 金剛般若経なんかは
「仏がいるということは 仏がいないということや」と
「徳があるということは 徳がないということだ」と
「菩薩は 一切衆生を救済するぞ と思わなきゃ 菩薩ではないんだけど」 と言って
「一切衆生を救済するぞ と思ったら」
「その意味は 一切衆生を救済しないということだ」と
というふうに いろいろ 面白く書いているんですね
ですから anattā っていうのは
智慧から成り立つ 結論ですね
でもそういうのは 言葉だけのことでね
ですから 苦 イコール 無我
「なんでそういうことを お釈迦様はおっしゃいますか？」 と言うと
これは 真理であって 事実ですから
これを理解すると 同時に
我々の 一切の苦しみが 消えちゃうんです
なぜ 人が苦しんでいるか というと
これ わかっていないんだから
「ものがある」と思っているんだから
あの花の例えで 考えてください
花が 我々は 「あまり長持ちはしないよ」と わかっているんだけど
花束を 家に持っていく間は
頭で 無常の概念を 否定するんですね
これは 家まで持っていって 花瓶に入れて
ああいう場所に 置いておきますよと
頭の中にもう 計画を立てているんですね
そのためには やっぱり 花が枯れてしまったら 困るんですね
永遠に いてくれなきゃ
そこで 電車に乗ったところで
さっと 次の駅で 人がいっぱい 入っちゃったら
もう潰れちゃったと いうところで
すごく 苦しみを味わう
「あぁ 嫌だ もったいないんだ」と
そこで 人によって変わりますけど 苦しみがね
まぁ あんまりものに囚われないで
「ま しょうがない 捨てましょう」となるかもしれませんし
でも 「ちょっと寂しい」と
それは ちょっとでも寂しい ということは 消えませんよ
「無常だ」と思った人は 花をその場で見て
「綺麗ですけど 帰りますよ」と帰りますからね
持っていかない
「だから 何ですか？」と
だから 執着はないんです 無常を知っている人にとっては
持っていかない
店にだって ものがある 「あれすごい綺麗です」
「綺麗ですけど だから何ですか？」という気持ちで
別に 「持っていこう 私にもひとつちょうだい」とかね
そこまでは いかないんです
だから 花束を持っていった人が
いくら できた人であろうと
持っていったこと自体が もう 一時的に無常は否定しているんですね
そこで 電車で潰れたりしたところで
「まぁ しょうがない 潰れちゃったんだから 捨てよう」というふうなことで
かすかにでも 寂しいと
もったいない という気持ちが あるかもしれません
より無常は 否定する人だったら
いろんな苦しみを 作るんですね
あるいは 自分に向かって
考える人だったら 「なんで 私みたいな バカがいるんですか？」
と
「人が こんなに来るんだったら」
「これは 上にあげて持っていた方が 良かったんではないか」とかね
あるいは 「棚の上に置いた方が 潰れなかったんではないか」とかね
「いつでも 自分がアホなことばっかり やっちゃうんだ」という感じで 苦しみを味わう
自分の問題ではなくて
「間違っているのは 他人だよ」と思っている人が
逆に 考えちゃうんですね
「なんで この人々は もう行儀が悪いこと」
「ざっと入るんだけど 人がいることは 考えてないんですか？」とかね
「自分が 乗ることしか 考えませんや」と
「他人に どれぐらい 迷惑を かけるか」とかね
そういうふうに 他人に当たるとかね
あるいは もうひとりは 全部まとめて 苦しむとかね
だから 苦しみの度合いが
その人その人 各自によって違いますけど
苦しむことだけは 確かなんですね
なんで 苦しんだかというと
無常を否定したからなんです
たとえ わずかな時間でも 無常を否定すると
苦しみが そこにあるんです
そういうわけで 人間が 何を理解するべきかというと
「無常であることは 理解するべきですよ」と
「そこで 限りない安らぎが 生まれるんだ」と
そういう順番で
「anattā 無我」が どんどん成り立っている
で anattā は なぜ入れたかというと
だいたい もう
人々が 余計なことを 考えるんですね
余計なことを考えると
「我」という感覚が 生まれちゃうんですね
あんまり 余計なことを考えないで
事実だけで留まっている人は いいんだけど
やっぱり 人々は よくよく考える
で 考えて 世の中で いろんな哲学を作っているんですね
それで 世の中で 「我」は 固定してしまったんです
そういうわけで 「仏教は 無我論をしゃべってるんではないか」と
言うようになってしまったんです
それで 時々 学者が 仏教の経典を読んでみたら
「あれ？ お釈迦様は 別に 無我論というふうにも言ってないんだ」と
それは正しいんです
「私は無我論を語っているぞ」とは 言っていないんだから
それで 間違っている学者が 何を言うかというと
「お釈迦様は 我は 否定してないんだ」と
「我の取り方が 間違っていると 言ってるだけですよ」と
という とんでもない間違いを 起こしちゃうんです
それも 単なる我論なんですね
日本の研究論文も ありますけど 同じことを言っている
でも 皆様あまり そういう批判されるのは嫌だから
インドにいた あの何でしたっけ
Sarvepalli Radhakrishnan という元の大統領
もう かなりの 立派な学者なんですけど
彼の 仏教について 書いている論文なんかございます
読んでみてください
彼が言うのは 「非我たることを 我で取ることは否定しただけです」
「人は 真我を置いておいて」
「真我でないものを 我だと勘違いすることは 批判しているだけですよ」
ということも言ってるんです
だから そういう話に 乗せられて
日本でも 書いているテキストでは やっぱり 同じことを言ったりはする
日本の研究の場合は 特色はあるんですね
で 他の学者の考え方は 真っ向から否定しない
ズルズルと
逃げる 抜けると
で それはまぁ
「自分が 怪我したくない」と言うならば
それは すごくいいかもしれませんけど
でも 人類に正しい知識を与えるのが 学者の仕事なんですね
だから 堂々と言うべきですね
自分が 感じたこと
だから 結構 まぁ 結構じゃなくて いくつか私も読んでみたんだけど
明確に 間違っていると 見えるんだけど
ズルズルと そちらは触らないことにして
次にっていう感じで いっちゃいますから
最終的には 本を読んで終わっても 何もないんですね 心に残ったことは
まぁ どんと 相手にぶつかって
こうで ああだ こうだと 言っちゃうと
何かこちらの知識として 残りますし
そういうことは 日本では ちょっとあることなんですけど
だから いろいろ読んだところでは
なんか 非我 無我とか ああだ こうだとかね
混乱は あるんです
じゃあ それで
「無我」という概念 これから「無我」に入ります
anattāっていうこと
それは anattāだから 否定形であって
これは ātman ではないんだと
だから肯定形は attā なんですね
attā ということで サンスクリット語だったら ātman なんですね
すぐ 人々が 「ātman 実体」
という 考え方を作ってしまったんです
作ってしまってから それを探すんです
「その ātman はどこにありますか？」と
ですから 最初から 仏教から言うと 「おかしい」と あなた方は
まず こういう概念だと決めて それを探す
研究の世界でも いくらかそういう傾向は ありますけど
まず仮説を立てて それに証拠を探すことは ありますけど
でも 問題は 仮説は いい加減に立てられますかね?
仮説を立てる時でも かなりの研究が必要なんです
研究なしに 仮説を立てられません
そこら辺も 気をつけてほしいんですが
要するに 仮説を立てる権利はあるし
仮説を立ててから それからもう 研究し続ける
それで それは成立するか 壊れるか どっちか わかりませんけど
でも 仮説を作るためには 十分な情報がなければ
立てられないはずなんです
そこで インドの世界を見ると
「そんなことない」
「世の中の どこを見ても 我があるのは 当たり前だ」と
もう決まってるんですね
決まってるんだけど 「じゃあ 見つけましょう」と それから 探すんです
で そういう探し方に
お釈迦様の すごく面白い例えが  ふたつありますけど
この例え ふたつも 現代の我々には ちょっと理解しにくいんですが
うーん まぁ 例えだからね
お釈迦様の言葉にしても
例えは 例えだから
その当時の人間が 当時の文化背景の中で 理解できるようなことだからね
教えは 現代人に わかりますけど
時々 例えがわからない  我々は
昔の インドのことだからね
ひとつの例えは こういう例えなんですね
人が はしごを作っているんだと
そこで知識人が いわゆる十字路のところで はしごを作っているんだと
それで いろんなところから 人が来て
「あんた何やってるの？」 「はしご作ってるんだ」と
「何のため?」
その pāsāda(パーサーダ) という言葉があります 「お城」
「お城に登るため」
「あ そう」 そこまではわかりますね
「お城を登るために はしごを作っているんだ」と
なんか合理的に見える
そこで その人々は こう聞くんですね
「お城は どこにあるんですかね？」
「わかりませんね」と 答えるんです
「あれは何階の建物？」 「わかりません」と
「じゃあ これは 東西南北の どこにあるの？」
「知りません そんなことは 」
「見たことはありますか？」
「いえ 見たことはないんだ」と
「見たことのないことだから 知りませんから」
「じゃぁ あんた このお城のことを 聞いたことは？」
「いいえ 聞いたこともないんだ」
「じゃあ わかった あんた そのお城があることさえ 知ってますか？だいたい」と
「それも知りません」
「と言うならば あんた 何のために このはしごを作ってる？」
「いえ、このはしごはもう お城を登るために 作っているんだ」と 言うとすると
「そうすると その人の言葉が何になるんですか？」と
その人は 何の根拠もない
ただ単に 頑張っているだけで
無意味だと
だから 存在しないお城に 登るために 作るはしごだと
という例えで お釈迦様は 何を言ってますかというと
発見もしていない 存在もしない「我」について しゃべっているのではないか と
すごく丁寧に 相手を侮辱しないで 言っていることなんです
それぐらいもう お釈迦様に できたんだけど
私には できないんだから
私は もう言う時は 言います
いくら腹が立っても 気にしないで
私はそんなに まぁ ただの人間だからね
お釈迦様みたいに 丁寧に言うってことは もう無理なんです
それで 皆様方 これから いろんな「我」について
すごい明確に書いているのは インドのテキストですからね
Upaniṣad(ウパニシャッド) テキストは あるし
日本訳は ございますし
で また いろんな瞑想 ヨーガとかね
Patañjali(パータンジャリ)とかね ヨーガ いろいろあるし
日本訳は 丁寧に書いてあります
読んでみてください すべて 「我」についてと 我を体験する方法
「我は なんですか？」と 誰も知らない
「我ってなんですか？自我 いわゆる実体ってなんですか？」と
だから お釈迦様は ちょっと からかっているだけ
次の例えも もっと ものすごく からかってるんだから
すごい単純な例えなんですけど
例えは ふたつあるんです 次の例えっていうのは
ある若者が 今は まぁ
もう結婚する年になったらね
「じゃぁ 結婚したらどうですか？」と
「あぁ そうですね 結婚します」と
「誰と結婚しますか？」と言うと
インドでは janapadakalyāṇī という
決まってる 美人の概念があったんですね
それも 今 現代で言えば
「ミス 何々」というふうな
全く同じことなんですね
その「ミス東京」「ミス ジャパン」とか言ってるでしょうし
そのミス東京には 「私はミス東京だ」と言っても もうなりませんからね
やっぱり みんな選べなくちゃいけないしね
「私は ミス ジャパンだよ」と言っても 誰もが 笑っちゃうだけでね
でも それを ちゃんとコンテストで選ばれたら もうミス ジャパンなんです
1年間は
そういう風に このjanapadakalyāṇī は 同じ意味なんですね
その国の美人ということで
私は現代風に ちょっとアレンジします そうでないとちょっと理解できません
「私は ミス ジャパンと結婚するんだ」と 同じことなんですね
そういうふうに 「私は こういう美人と結婚するんだ」と
「あぁ そう その人は どこにいるんですか？」と
「わかりません」と
「そんな人いるんですか？」と言うと 「いるかどうかもわかりません」と
「クシャトリヤですか？ バラモンカーストですか？」
「ヴァイシャですか？ シュードラ カーストの人ですか？ 知ってますか？」
「それも知りません」と
だから 「あなたはね 何の根拠もない くだらないことを言ってるだけや」と
何か知っているならば 探せるでしょうに
例えば 「この美人が バラモンカーストや」と言ったら
東にいるか 西にいるか わからなくても
片っ端から バラモンカーストの女の人を 調べてみれば 見つかるでしょうし
無理かもしれませんけど
一応 論理的に可能性ぐらいでも ありますね
例えば この海岸に
「海岸に 純金の砂が 一粒ありますよ」と言ったら
それでもいいんです
論理的に成り立つんです
どこの海岸とは 言ってないんです
それでも 論理的には 探すことは可能なんです
論理的に
ある人が もう片っ端から 地球上にある海岸を
全部1粒1粒 砂を調べれば
調べれば その純金の砂の1粒が 見つかる可能性はありますね
だから 方法論は成り立ちます
実践的に 可能か不可能かは 置いておいて
お釈迦様が言うのは 「それでもないんだ」と
「あんた方が 言うことは」
「それぐらいも 探す方法はないんだ」と
ですから それはヨーロッパで
イギリスで この なんとか哲学派が 生まれたんですね
彼らが よく言うのは meaningless(ミーニングレス) meaningful(ミーニングフル) という言葉で
何哲学者でしたっけ？
もう随分昔の話 勉強だから もう忘れちゃった
あの哲学者で 最近の Bertrand Russell(バートランド・ラッセル)も それに入っちゃうし
もう何人かの 有名な人々が作った考え方なんですね
言葉には 意味があるか ないか ということを調べる
だから その最近 流行っているものなんですけど
お釈迦様も その立場で 昔から よくしゃべっていたんですね
言うことには 何も 何といいますか？
土台も 根拠も 何もなく
ただ口先だけ 言葉だけで言う ということで
それで とにかく みんな 問題を起こしたのは
ātman 実体がある ということを まず決めて
それに方法を探す それを見つける方法
探す前には 仮定を作る前に 仮説を作る前には
それなりの何か 探すための根拠やら 方法やらが 必要なんですね
それはなかったと
それで お釈迦様のやり方っていうのは
「私たちは 何を知ってますか？」
「何を経験していますか？」と
「私たちの すべての知識 智慧が どのように生まれるか？」
「我々は 何を知っているか？」ということで
そこに 「その状態は 何ですか？」と言えば
「ずっと変化するんだから 成り立つんだ」と
それで 必然的な結論として 「無我ですよ」ということ
成り立つんですね
そういうわけで
お釈迦様は そこでまた実践的になって 「無我論だよ」とは言わないんです
「無常だよ」で また止まるんです
「無常から先に 自分でいってください」と
で 1時間ちょうど 経過しましたので
私は疲れてませんけど
まだ 話し始めていないんだから
ちょっと 5分ぐらい お休みを取ってください
ということで 人間が頭で想像した
どこにあるかわからない 我について
いろいろ困ったり 考えたりした時代で
お釈迦様は 我というものは どういうものかと
また具体的に 明確に
再び
考えてあげたということで
無我論の2部に 入ります
一番最初に
「私に自我があるんだ」と言う場合は
この「私」という問題が大事なんですね
「私に魂があるんだ」と
「私に 何か 私たる実体があるんだ」と 言っているんですね　世の中で
そこで ヨーガやら 瞑想やらする人々も
この「私たるものを 発見しよう」と 頑張っているんですね
で これは インドの文化で
違う世界にしても
「私には魂があるんだ」と決めつけて
「発見しなくても あるんだから」と
インド人は「やっぱり 体験しましょう」ということは あったんだけど
インド以外の世界では 別に
「まぁ あるんだから もう いいんじゃないか 」と それぐらいで
ということで 死んだら魂は もう
永遠になりますからと 落ち着いているんですね
頑張ろう ということはないんです
そこで お釈迦様は 「じゃあ 私は って 何ですか?」と
まず 「私に魂がある」ということじゃなくて
「私は」「私」という
「我々 言うそのものを 客観的に 見てみよう」と
と言うと お釈迦様は 5つに分けちゃうんですね
で からだを 5つに分ける
Rupa(ルーパ) Vedanā(ヴェーダナー) Saññā(サンニャー) Sankāra(サンカーラ) Viññāna(ヴィンニャーナ)
決まってる 仏教用語はありますけど
また 言葉を入れちゃったら
ちょっと 問題が起こりますので
それは 後で考えましょう
これは 大体 人間のからだを 分けていることで
それで お釈迦様は ものすごい 分類の ノウハウを持っていて
分類することはね
「これに 異常なものがあるんだったら 言ってくれ」 という状態なんです
この 5つは 誰にでも また 経験できるものなんですね
Rupa Vedanā Saññā Sankāra Viññāna という 5つで
この「私」 そのものが できているんだと
それから 説明に行きます
あまり時間がないのに たくさん ありますからね
「Rupa って何ですか？」 というと
この体なんですね
物体としての体
それだけは 誰にでもわかります
体という この物体 この機械
細胞でできている このものが Rupa というんですね
そこで 問題解決しておきましょう
この体っていうのは
「体に 何か体たる実体が ありますか？」と
この現代知識から見ても
我々には よくわかっていることで
我々は 一個の細胞から スタートするんだけど
その細胞は分裂して 今の体ができているんですね
それで その
ずっと 同じ細胞で生きてるんですかね？
そういうわけじゃ ないんですね
それぞれ一個の細胞には あまり長い寿命はないんです
私は はっきりとはわかりませんけど
おそらく 3ヶ月ぐらいだろうと 思いますけどね
そこら辺は 皆様の知識で 正しい日にちを理解してください
あまり そこら辺は 勉強してないんです
一応 仮に 3ヶ月間と言いましょう
で 細胞が 3ヶ月間いたら 死んでしまうんですね
その代わりに 新しいものが生まれてくる
で そこで 生きているということになる
今も 細胞が死んでいく
その代わりに 新しい細胞が生まれる
その新しい細胞を作る材料は どこから取るんですかね？
0.1ミリグラムとは 言えないんですね
初めの細胞っていうのは
ほんの小さいものが 今は キロ単位で 計算してるでしょうに
「50 キロや 60 キロや」とかね
それぐらい重さが出たのは どこから出たんですかね？
ずっと 外にある物質が入って
新しいシステムを作って
それまた その物質は 出ていく
それで 母親のお腹の中で 生まれた細胞は
とっくに お腹の中で もう死んじゃったんです
後から できた
母親の体から入ってきた栄養やら そういうものから 材料を取って
作った細胞の塊が 生まれるんでしょうし
それまた みるみるうちに 体が新しく変わっていくんですね
これで 細胞の次元から考えても
この体には 何も変化しないものはない
これはもう 原子単位で考えても
変化しないものは何もない
ずっと変化していく
いわゆる実体は ない
で お釈迦様は 簡単に聞くのは
「あなたの体は 変化するか しないか」と 質問するんです
「niccaṃ vā aniccaṃ vā?」と
パーリ語の お釈迦様の言葉
rūpaṃ, bhikkha ve, niccaṃ vā aniccaṃ vā?
「rūpaṃというものは 比丘らよ」
「niccaṃ 永遠か aniccaṃ 無常か」
いつでも お釈迦様が聞く質問は すごい簡単なんです
niccaṃ vā
aniccaṃ vā?
これは質問なんです 1行に書かなくちゃいけないんです
もし パーリ語も 覚えておきたいと
お釈迦様の言葉通りに 覚えておきたいならば 全部書いておきます
rūpaṃ, bhikkha ve,
bhikkhave というのは呼ぶ言葉
rūpaṃ ルーパは
bhikkha ve 比丘らよ と呼ぶんです
niccaṃ vā 永遠か？
aniccaṃ vā 無常か？
nicca というのは 変化しないもの 永遠なもの
anicca というのは 否定形ですね
日本語になると 言葉が 逆になっちゃいますけどね
変化するものか 変化しないものか
なんか nicca っていうのは 言葉がない
無常から言えば 常住か 無常か というふうなことでね
だから rūpaṃ, bhikkha ve, niccaṃ vā aniccaṃ vā?
聞いたら 当然出てくる答えは何ですかね？
「この体が 変化しますか？ 変化しないか？」 と聞けば
当然 それには 誰でも 当たり前で 答えなくちゃいけないことは
aniccaṃという答えなんですね
aniccaṃ お釈迦様に言う場合は また bhante
aniccaṃ, bhante.
会話形式だから やっぱり 人を呼ぶ
で この同じパーリの言葉が こちらにも つながりますからね
Rūpaには 本当は これが入りますけどね
上のこれは 私が書いたものじゃない
これは何？これは 傷跡みたい
点は下に入ります
この体 個体 物体は
常か 無常か でもいいんですけど
「永久的に 変化しないものか？ 変化するものですか？」と言ったら
答えは 「変化するものですよ」と
そこで 変化するものは 評価する場合は
「まぁ 変化するんだから 何の意味もないってことで 無効ですよ」と
「じゃぁ 変化するものは 実体ですか？」と
変化しないものの中に
変化するものの中に
「変化するものが 変化しないものですか？」と聞いているのと 同じなんです
ですから attan は 聞かない その場合は
「じゃぁ 無常であるならば あなたはどう思いますか？」
「この rūpa自体が その体 物体自体が ātmanだと」
「我だと 観察することは 正しいか ないか？」と
「正しくないんだ」と
理屈は簡単です
「無常たるものは 無常でないと考えることは 正しいか？」と聞いているんです
体が無常でしょ
「無常たるこの体が 無常じゃないと考えることは 正しいか ないか？」と
そしたら 「正しくないんだ」と
ですから パーリ語で言えば
kallaṃ nu taṃ samanu…
Yaṃ aniccaṃ taṃ dukkhaṃ.
Yaṃ dukkhaṃ kallaṃ nu taṃ samanupassituṃ:
eso'ham asmi, eso me attā.
という ちょっと文章が長いんですけど そちらの ものすごい
Upaniṣadの世界で 哲学者が考えた 同じ言葉を借りて 言ってるんですね
「無常たる この rūpa が 私ですよ」と
「私の我ですよ と考えることは 正しいか？」と
と聞いたら 「正しくないんだ」と
それで お釈迦様は 最後に
「じゃぁ 無常であるならば」
「苦 dukkha であるならば」
「苦であるならば また 実体ではないんだから 捨てましょう」
「持っていく必要ないでしょ」
「それに対する あなたの未練 希望 欲望」
「じゃぁ 全部捨てましょう」と
それで それは終わります
同じように次々 続きます
次に Vedanā
Vedanā は
一番大事なポイントで
物体というならば
私も物体であって この机も物体なんですね
椅子も 物体なんですね
この建物は 物体なんですね
物体として見ると 別になんの差もないんです
でも 私と机は 本当に同じか というと 同じじゃないんですね
私は ご飯 食べてるんだからね
机は 全然食べてないしね
ですから やっぱり違うんですね
何か違う
この何か違うところを みんな 誤解するんですね
そこで この何か違うところは 次から説明するんです
私と机と 一番違うところは vedanā 感じること
感覚
vedanā っていうのは 感じること 感覚のことなんですね
で 建物は 何も感じないんです
机も何も感じない でも 私は 感じちゃうんですね
寒さ 感じる
暑さ 感じる
何かが触れたら すぐわかるんですね
その 感じる という働きがあるんです
じゃぁ 次に それについて聞くんです
「その感じることが 変化しないか 変化しますか？」と
ものすごい わかりやすい質問なんです
「あなたが感じることは 変化するか 変化しないか？」と
感じるということは
これは 体より早く変化するんです
で 私の体がね もう一応
変化はしていますけど そんなに見える変化がないでしょう
もう 1ヶ月間ぐらいでも 経たないと
今日 ご飯を食べなかったんだからと サッと 痩せることはないんだから
やっぱり 2日  3日  4 日間 ご飯食べないでいると
ゆっくり痩せてきますからね
そんなものじゃない 感じるということは
寒い空気が入ると すぐもう「あ 寒い」と
暖かい空気が触れた瞬間に 「あ 暖かい」と
瞬時に 変わるでしょう
で 瞑想する時でも 座っていると すごく足が痛くてとかね
立った瞬間に もう変わっちゃうでしょうに
だからこのvedanā
「感じることは 変化するものか 変化しないものか？」と聞くときは
当然な答えは 「変化するものや」と
それで 変化するものだから
それに 「すごいありがたい 私ものや」と捕まるべきかと
何か 「あ 気持ちよかった」と
それは ずっと そのままあるんですかね？
気持ちよかった瞬間に 変化するんだから
だから 「それもdukkhaであって 無我ですよ」と
「感覚自体は 当然無我ですよ」と はっきりと言っています お釈迦さまは
変化するんだから 実体はない
実体はないでしょうに 例えば私の手で こうやって触る感覚と
何か針でも持ってきて 同じところを触るときの感覚は 違うでしょうに
だから その原因によって 感覚が変わりますから
気持ちいいか 悪いかっていうことは
ですから すごく 無常でありまして
原因によって 生まれるのであって 実体はない
魂は とにかく 感覚には ないと 決める
それで 「なんで そんなことを言いますか？」 と言うと
「この感じることは魂や」と 言っている人が いるんです
いたんです 今もいるんですけど
それで お釈迦様は 「それは そうじゃないか」と
別に 否定している ということじゃなくて
「ただ どうですかね？ 客観的に見れば」と ただそれだけ
ですから お釈迦様のキーワードは いつも 無常から始まるんです
「その感覚自体がどうですかね 無常か そうでないか？」と
「変化しないか 変化するか？」と
「変化はするんだ」と
「では 変化するんだったら 実体だとは 言えますかね？」と
「あ それは言えません」と
それで vedanāは 同じく無我であると 決められる
決めるしか 道がないんです
次に Saññā ということ
Saññā っていうのは
私は 理解しやすくするために
我々の この 知識みたいなもんだと
と覚えておいてください
厳密に アビダンマ的に解釈しちゃうと
ものすごい ややこしくて わからなくなりますから
簡単にわからなきゃ また意味がないんですね
で 私たちには もういっぱい 知識のようなものが あるんですね
この知識というのは 「私は勉強していないんだから 知識がないんだ」というのは
それは嘘であって 知識がなければ 生きていられないんです
犬にもありますから
だから「私たちにはない」と言っても 私は聞きません そんな話は
犬にも ミミズにも あります 知識は
どういうことかというと
ミミズは 何を食うべきか 何を食べてはいけないかを 知っているんだから
どこに 穴を掘ればいいかと 知ってるでしょうに
それは 知識なんです
これは バラの花だ
これは 桜の花だという
そういう 区別できる能力
それは知識なんです
そこで 勉強する人々は さらに区別できる能力が 増えるだけ
役に立たないんだけど
ですから この知識というものは ミミズにもあるんだから
アメーバにも ありますからね
ないとは言えません
それは saññā というんです
だから 知識には 違う言葉があります
言葉をもって 操っている知識には
仏教では 別な言葉を使ってますけど
ですから これはもう 生命の基本だから
その言葉を使わない
Saññā だから だいたい お分かりになると思いますけどね
だから ミミズさえも アメーバさえも 生きている場合は
自分で使っている そのノウハウ
それに saññāと言うんです
それで問題は その saññā自体が 変化するか しないかということ
どうですかね？
我々は このノウハウを持っている
ノウハウというか 知識というか
「生き続けるために 我々が使っている そのエネルギーが 変化しますか しないか？」と
当時の人は 当然 「あれは変化しますよ」と
わかります
どうしても わからないと言うならば
なんで 勉強するんですかね？
勉強すると 何が成長するんですかね？
saññā が 成長するんです
区別 判断できる能力が
分別 判断できる能力が 成長するだけのことで
「英語を勉強するんだ」と言っても
ただ音を聞いたら 違う感覚を作る ということだけでしょうに
その立場で英語を勉強してください
早く勉強できるんです
Good Morning(グッドモーニング) という言葉は
辞書を引いて「good って何ですか？」と
「morning は 何ですか？」とかね
それで勉強できないんです
例えば 「おはようございます」と言う時の その言葉
その音について
「おはようございます」という音について どんな感覚か？ と
じゃあ Good Morning と言ったら もう同じことと
音を入れ替えれば 同じことです
pencil(ペンシル)と言っても 鉛筆と言っても
ただ音は違うだけで ものは同じものなんです
だから この saññā の立場から勉強しちゃうと
随分早く 語学は 勉強できるんです
なぜならば 人間というのは 感じることは みんな同じ
ほとんど同じだから
自分を産んだ人について ある感じが 誰でも同じことでしょうに
それに father(ファーザー) mother(マザー) というか
お母さんというか
お袋さんとか なんとか言うか
どっちでも 同じことだと
じゃぁ  saññā が 変化する ということは そこでわかりますね
いろんなことを勉強すると
我々の saññā の世界が 変わるでしょうに
変わらなきゃ 勉強できない
saññā が変わらなきゃ
もう全然 どんな言葉を聞いても
まるっきり 何の変化もないはずなんです
それで saññā 自体が 無常であることはわかります
そこだけじゃない そうすると 増えるばっかりではないかと
そこは ありがたい話なんですね
勉強すれば するほど 増えるばっかり
増えるばかり？ 減るんです
増えると同時に 減ってもいくんです
勉強したものは 忘れちゃうし
あまりにも 減りすぎて
もうね 年取ったところで
時々 年取らなくてもね
アルツハイマーに なっちゃったら
みるみるうちに saññā がなくなっちゃうでしょうに
そこで 自分の大便も 食べてしまうでしょ
持ってる saññā は 食べ物という saññā だけ
で 見たものは 「食べ物や」と 勘違いするんです
実際は 自分の 大便かもしれません
何のことなく食べる
で ボケてる人に 何か紙でも 絵はがきでも 見せちゃったら
何のことなく つぶして 食べると
あるでしょ？
で 私たちは ああだ こうだとか 何を言っても 別に何のこともなく
無常だから saññā が
その方に残っている saññā は ただそれだけ
生きるためには 食べるってことが 必要だから
なんか それだけ 残っている
もし そのボケてる人の場合
先に 食べるという saññā が 消えちゃったら その人は食べないんです
なんも
体が いくら痩せても 飢え死になっても 食べなくなっちゃうんです
食べるという saññā が消えちゃったら
食べ物という saññā が消えちゃったら
だいたいは この基本的な saññā っていうのは
結構 続けていくんです
そういうことで 「saññā は 変化するか しないか？」と聞いたら
それは 変化する
みるみるうちに 変化する
どれぐらい変化するかというと
私は 一生懸命 今しゃべってるんだけど これ 出たら 全部 忘れちゃうでしょうに
全部 テープレコーダーのせいにする
簡単に 忘れちゃうんです
だから まぁ
だからこの saññā を 忘れるスピードが遅い人は よく勉強できる人だと
強烈な勢いで忘れる人には 勉強できないんだと
「いくら教えても あなたはダメや」と言うんですね
それは別に 教える時は その人は理解するんです
理解はするんだけど もう立ったら 終わりと
お釈迦様は ある経典で こう言うんですね
「いろんな人が いるんだ」と言って
ある人が この
「その人の智慧が 膝の上に 物を置くことと同じだ」と
膝の上に物を置くと 立ったら 全部落ちちゃうでしょうし
そういうふうに 「一生懸命 説法を聞いても 立ったら忘れますよ」と
「そういう人もいるんだ」と
それで もうひとりがいて
「ザルに 水を汲むような人や」と
ザルに水を入れることと同じだと
いくら入れても そうっと その瞬間で 通っていってしまうと
それは知識の世界 それも知識と saññā は 同じなんですけどね
ですから saññā っていうのは 当然変化するもの
「そこに 実体がありますか？」と
例えば 「これはバラの花だよ」と 分別する
私の機能に 分別できるその機能に 実体があるかというと
そこには 実体がないでしょうし
ですから 「saññā は無我である」と
次に Sankāra  これは複数形で Sankārā(サンカーラー)
これはひとつ これはひとつ 働きとしては
感じることは ひとつ
Saññā はひとつ 分別判断の能力だから
Sankārā は たくさんあります
Sankārāっていうのは
私は 最近 いろいろ研究して
本を書いた お坊さんのテキストから
それが わかりやすいんだから 言いますけど
人間の心の中で いつでもあるんですね
なんか もうエネルギーがあるんです
「なんか やらなくちゃ」というエネルギー
この 「何かやらなくちゃ」 というエネルギーは
「生きていかなくちゃ」と 同じ気持ちなんですね
それで ずっと 人間は動いてるんです
ご飯作るは ご飯食べるは
服を洗うは 服は着るは 寝るは 歩くは
仕事をするは もう いろんなことを やっているんです
瞬間も 止まりません
「何かやらなくちゃ」という気持ちは ずっとあるんです
それ なくなったら 死んじゃうんです
で 呼吸さえ 吸ったら 吐かなくちゃと
吐いたら 吸わなくちゃ ということで 成り立ってるんです
だから この呼吸瞑想を ずっとさせると それがよくわかるんです
吸ったところで 吐きたくなる
吐いたところで 吸いたくなる
だから 止めることなく 吸ったり 吐いたりしている
ご飯を食べると やめたくなる
それから また 食べたくなる
それで また食べる それまた 止めたくなると
そういうふうに いつでも 何かしたくなる
食べたくなる 止めたくなる
それをストップしたら どうなるんですかね？
食べたくなる それは ずっと永久的に あるんだと言えば
その人は 食べる 食べる 食べる 終わらないでしょうに
死んじゃうんです
そういう 生きるものに
生きているものに すべての生きている生命に
この生きるということは 「何かしなくちゃという」という その気持ちなんです
それは 今の人間には すごいことで
なんか やることがなければ 怖くて たまらなくなっちゃうんです
退屈で やることないと
たまらなくなるんです
だから いっぱい 仕事を わざと作るんです
例えば 休みだったら
「休みの時は 何をしますか？」と また決めるんです
計画 スケジュールを作るんです
作って それをやるんです
何もやることないと 趣味でも作って それをやっているんですね
やっぱり 何かやる ということは 生きる ということで
やることが 少なくなると 生きる元気が少なくなる
当然のことです
すごく退屈になって あまりにもやることが なくなってしまうと 鬱でしょうに
それで 自殺しちゃうんですね
でも 自殺したいということも やりたいということなんです
結局 抜けられない sankāra からは
世間のことで 「何もやることはない 面白くない」と
「部屋から出たくないんだ」と
人としゃべりたくないんだと
言って パジャマのまんまで 1 日中いるとかね
それで あまりにも退屈で
また 何かやりたくなる
やりたくなって 自殺もするということ
どう見ても やりたくなるということだけは 生命には もうずっとある
それは消えない
まぁ 消えないであるんだけど
問題は 「それは変化しますか 変化しないか？」ということなんです
どうですかね？
すぐ変化するでしょうに
その場に その場に おいて
瞬時に変化する やりたいということ
例えば 映画見たいと思ったりする
それで そこまで行く 行ったところで今日は休館だと
「じゃあ 帰ってお茶でも 飲もう」となっちゃうんでしょうに
瞬時に変わる やりたいことは
だから この生きる衝動としての sankāra なんですけど
それはもう いつ
瞬時に 瞬時に 変わって 変わっていくんです
それは 人々が「魂だ」と 誤解している場合もありますね
「私には 神様に決められた 試練があるんだ」とかね
「人間は ここで生まれたのは 何か目的があって生まれたんだ」とかね
ああいうのは もういい加減な 根拠のない ただの言葉の遊びなんですね
そんなに試練があるならば 「何ですか？」と 聞いたらわからないでしょうに
「なんで あなたは 生まれたんですか？」と聞いたら わかるんですかね？
どんな人間も 誰も わかってないでしょうに
ただやりたいんだから 何かやっている途中で 勘違いするんです
ヒトラーさんみたいに
どうも じっとしていられない 精神的な病気で
ヒトラーですか？ アドルフ・ヒトラーという人がね
そうすると その人が いろいろやっているところで
人を抑えるは 殺すは いろんなことをやって
どんどん どんどん やって
刺激が出てきて 「私は もう選ばれているんだ」と
言うことだけであって
選ばれているか もう 死んじゃったんだからね
そういうのは 嘘でしょうし
だから 「私には 何かやるべき仕事が
あるんだ」 とか言うのは やっぱり 同じことで
いろんなことを やっていると
あれは 「なんか やらなくちゃいけない」という気持ちは いつでも ありますからね
だから 「やっぱり やるべき仕事は あるんだ」と思い 勘違いするだけ
やるべき仕事は あるんじゃなくて
「なんか やらなくちゃいけない」 という気持ちがあるんだと
「それは何ですかと 私も わかりません」と
やりたいのは私ですけど
「何がやりたいかと わからない」というのは 事実なんです
それで その周りにある 何か やっているんです
山の中で生まれて 山の中で育った人間だったら
そこら辺で 何かやってるんです
東京で生まれ 東京で育った人は そこら辺で 何かやってるんです
それで とにかく 人間の 生命の心の中に
「何かやらなくちゃ」 という気持ちがあるんです
それは 人間の哲学と違うところは
これは 生命の論理だから
アメーバにも あることなんです
アメーバも 「何かやらなくちゃ」という気持ちが あるんだからこそ
「ちょっと 先に進まなくちゃいけない」 と
「この餌を 食わなくちゃいけない」 という気持ちは あるんです 言葉じゃないんです
「分裂しなくちゃ」という 気持ちがなければ 分裂しませんでしょうし
生きていられないんです sankāra がなければ
そこで アメーバには 微かなんですけど
人間には すごい いろんなことがある
人間が わざと強引に 作った sankāraが いっぱいありますね
「建物を 作らなくちゃ」とかね
「経済活動しなくちゃ」とかね
「原子爆弾を 作らなくちゃ」とかね
いろんな sankāra が 生まれてくる
そこで その やりたがるエネルギーなんですね
それにも たくさんあります
それから 私たちに生まれる 怒りやら 嫉妬やら
慈しみやら そういう感情は sankāra に 入っちゃうんですね
そういうものが生まれても やっぱり 何か やりたくなっちゃうんですね
嫉妬が生まれたら 何かやりたくなる
怒りが生まれたら 何かやりたくなる
慈しみの気持ちが 生まれても
何かやりたくなる ということで 全部 ひとつに まとめられます
だから 人間の 一般的に 我々が知っている感情と
この やりたい やりたい という気持ちを まとめて sankārā と言うんです
だから たくさんあります
で 人間には たくさんあるんだけど 犬にもあります
犬にある sankāraと 私が持っている sankāraが まるっきり同一のものかって
それは違うんです
でも 質としては 同じ
犬には 100あるならば 人間には 1億あるかもしれません
ただそれだけ
Sankāra に 変わりがない
そこで その sankāra は お釈迦様の また前の質問
Sankhārā, bhikkhave, niccā vā aniccā vā?
「Sankhārāというものは niccā ですか 変化しないか？」
「aniccaṃ あるいは 変化しますか？」と
答えは 決まってて 変化するでしょうに
みるみるうちに 変化するでしょうに
ここに ケーキが ひとつあって 見たところで
「あ 食べたい」と 気持ちが生まれるでしょうに
「食べたい」と言ったところで 私が 「いえ 本当は 私は それを 舐めたんですよ」と
「舐めてみたんだけど 美味しかったよ」と言ったら
どんな気持ちですか？ その場合は
「あぁ 嫌ですよ 食べたくない」 という気持ち sankāra が生まれる
瞬時に
原因が 変わったんだから 条件が 変わったんだから
それよりも もっとひどい例えで 言っちゃいます
僕は これ試したことなんですけど
ある人に なんか「食べ物を どこで買ったの？」
「いや そこらから拾ってきたんですよ」 と言ったら
食べないんです
まぁ バカだから アホでしょ
そんな 人に 拾ってきたものを あげるわけじゃないし
どうせ 正真正銘 これは買ってきたものってわかっているのに
人間ってのは 本当に どこまで愚かかっていうことも ありますけど
それは 私の 個人的な楽しみで
もう 拾ってきた
で 食べなかったんですね
で 食べないと僕は 怒ってね
「あんた 本当に何て 馬鹿者か」と
「もうちょっと 合理的に 考えてください」と
だからその sankāra っていうのはそんなもんで
もう ほんのちょっとのことで 変化する
だから sankāra自体 「何かやりたい」 という 我々の心の中にある
ずっとある この感じが 魂じゃない
自我ではない 実体ではない
勘違いする気持ちは わかります ずっとあるんだから
やりたい 生きたいという気持ちが
ずっとあるんだから 魂だと勘違いするのは 気持ちはわかるんだけど
ちょっと見ると 合理的に
これ すごい 強烈な勢いで 変化する
ですから 「sankāra も無我である」と
そこで 最後に Viññāna が出てきます
Viññāna っていうのは
簡単な言葉で言えば 「心」というものなんですけど
それでも わからないと思いますから
こういう風に
この机と 私が違うでしょ
どこで違うかというと
その 私に 心という認識する働きがあるんですね
認識するという
外の世界
机と 私の違うところは ただそれだけ
私は 外の世界はあると 知っている
机は 知らない
その働きで viññāna というんです
心ですね 認識 「識」ですね
仏教用語では「識」というんです
認識の識
だから そこも 永久的にあるかというと そうじゃないと
だって 人が死ぬのは 当然 見えるでしょうに
そこで 認識することは 止まるでしょうし
それでも 心は無常ということは 見えるし
その認識するということは なぜ無常かというと
バラの花を認識する
全く同じ心で ご飯は 認識できないんです
そうすると バラの花見ても
ご飯見ても バラの花に見える可能性があります
認識することは 心だから
だから
これすごい 無常なんです
建物を見たら 「建物や」と認識する
椅子を見たら 「椅子だ」と認識する
同じ認識だったら 建物見ても 同じもの
椅子を見ても 同じものに なってしまうんですね
ですから 区別判断は できなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから 心っていうのは ずっと変化します
それでも わからないんだったらね
やっぱり「あなた方の心は 変わりませんか？」と
「見てください」と 「変わるでしょうに」
「この人と 一生 生活しますよ」と思っても
もう 1年 2年で 「もう やめます」と いうことに なるでしょうに
心は みるみるうちに 変わってしまう
ですから 心というものも
識というものも 無常であって
だから 無我であると 決めるんですね
で 次 そういうわけで
「私」を お釈迦様は ５つに分ける
その分け方の 不思議なことっていうのは
それは 人間の体の分析ではありません
一切の生命は そういうふうに 成り立っているということ
人間だけではない 神々も この 5つを 持ってるんです
だから ミミズと アメーバと 私たちは 体を持ってるんだけど
体は それぞれ違うでしょうし
そのように 神であろうが もっと 上の生命であろうが
幽霊であろうが 誰であろうが 関係ないんだけど
やっぱり それなりに この 5つがあるんです
だから 誰にあっても
「これは基本的な働きだから それは無常ですよ」と
「無常の塊ですよ」と
「だから そこには我が見つかりません」と
からだの中では
からだの中に 見つからなかったら それで終わりでしょ 問題は
それで 時々 馬鹿者が 「からだの外で探すんだ」 とやっちゃうんです
自分の中に魂がなければ それで 問題は終わりますけど
「いえ 外にあるんじゃないかな」と
それにも お釈迦様は違う経典で 説明しちゃうんです
こういう 例えば
「Rupaは nicca か anicca か？」 と聞いて
「永遠か 変化するか？」 と聞いて 「変化しない」
「変化しないものは dukkha か ないか？」 で 「dukkha ですよ」と
「Dukkha たるものは 無我ですか 我ですか？」と 言われたら
「無我ですよ」と お坊さんたちが 答えるんです
そこで お釈迦様は言うんです
「だから 過去であろうが rupa は rupa だから」
「現在の rupa も rupa だから」
「未来の rupa も rupa だから」
「内の rupa も rupa だから」
「外の世界の rupa も rupa だから」
「rupaは 無我ですよ」と
簡単でしょ 論理は
だから 外に探すのは バカらしいんですね
「私には 真我がないんだけど 神様に 真我があるんだ」と言ういうのは
全く 仏教から見れば もう無意味な話なんですね
rupa の立場から考えちゃうと
「こちらに rupa があって それは無常で無我ですよ」
「いや わかった」と だから
こちらにあるのは rupa でしょうに
あちらにあるのも rupa でしょうに
だから過去であろうが
未来であろうが 現在であろうが
ここに 中のものであろうが
外のものであろうが 遠いもの 近いもの
いろんな言葉を使って
Yaṃ dūre yaṃ santike あぁ
Yaṃ hīnaṃ yaṃ paṇītaṃ
Yaṃ sukhumaṃ とか
あるいは すごい微細な きめ細かいものであろうが rupa だから
あるいは 大きな地球みたいに 太陽みたいに
宇宙みたいな 巨大なものまである
rupa でしょ 結局は
物質でしょ
ということで きれい さっぱり 我を否定するんです
同じことが Vedanā Saññā Sankāra Viññāna に行くんです
そういうふうに 無我っていうのは
じわじわと 無我の理解に 行かなくちゃいけない
そこで もうひとつ 時間は終わりましたけど
お釈迦様は こう言うんですね
「もし rupa の中で これと 言うくらい 」
「ほんの ちょっとでも」
ということは 現代的に言えば 素粒子ぐらいでも
「無常でないもの 自我であるものが あるならば」
「私は あなた方に 解脱しなさいと 言いません」と
で Vedanā Saññā Sankāra Viññāna にも 同じことを言うんです
それぐらい明確に 「無我だよ」と 言ってるんですけど
「そうじゃない」と言う人々は いるんです
素晴らしい 国際的な すごい有名な学者の方々も 言ってはいるんですけどね
それはもう 勉強が足らないということでね
学者に限って 勉強しませんからね
で まぁ そういうことで
お釈迦様は もう綺麗に
人を五蘊に この５つに分けたこと自体で
この 世の中のすべての哲学に 答えているんです
「神様は 私を作ったか 自然に現れたか？」とかね
あるいは「人間は偶然に生まれたか？」とか
いろんなことの話は あるでしょうに
「生命誕生」「偶然だ」 ああだこうだ 全部に答えているのです
まぁ とにかく 「この５つですよ」と
そこに神は成り立たなくなるんですから
それで十分だよ お釈迦様にとっては
私は頭が悪いんだから
「神はありません いません」と
言うと 神を信じている人々には すごく失礼なことを言われたことになりますけど
お釈迦様は「まぁ 人っていうのは こういう５つでしょう」ということで
もう何のことなく あの考え方は 相手にしていない
で もうひとつ ワンステップ進んで言うならば
人間は すべてのものは認識して 理解して しゃべっているでしょうし
たとえ 「神がいる 魂がある」
「私は永遠なものや」と 言うことも
そもそも 人間の理解なんですね
それは確かなんです 理解していないものは しゃべれないでしょうに
考えていないものは しゃべれないでしょうに
だから 人間しゃべっている
考えているすべては 人間の理解で 経験であります
それは ものすごい究極的な瞑想をしている
もうすごい 昔にいた仙人たちであろうが
自分たちが感じたものを しゃべっているんです
「brahman(ブラフマン)が いるんだ」とか
あるいは 念仏なんか唱えるとか
真面目に頑張ってね 「阿弥陀様が現れてくるんだ」という話もあるしね
そういうのは その本人が 正直なものだと仮定すると
まぁ ほとんど正直でない場合もありますけど
正直なものだと仮定して考えると
その人には 見えたものなんです
「阿弥陀様が見えた」と言う
そういうふうに 人間が語っている
宗教 哲学を始めてからある すべてのもの
「神がいる」ということも 「神がいない」ということも
「阿弥陀さんがいる」ということも 「いない」ということも
「仏教は正しい」ということも 「正しくない」ということも
どっちでも 人間の理解でありますね
それにも あまり異論ないでしょ
うん じゃあ それからいってみましょう
人間が 物事をどのように理解するかと
そこでこれ 五蘊ですから
皆様知ってますね 色受想行識という日本語の言葉
人間は どのように物事を理解するかというと こういう
chakkhu
sota
ghāna
jivhā
kāya
manaという ６種類の働きが からだにあるんです
chakkhuは眼 sotaは耳
ghānaは嗅覚 鼻
jivhāは舌 味の味覚
kāyaは体ですね 体の外側と内側の感覚ですね 体の
manaっていうのは 人間の意識ですね 心
それ以外 我々に情報が入る方法は ありますか？
その からだに 情報が入る窓口でしょ
そこで すべての生命には こんなもんです
ミミズには 目がないんだけど
アメーバの目も耳もないんだけど からだがあるんですね
２つぐらいあります 体と 判断できるんだから 意識っていうのはあるんです
人間には ６つ揃っている
7番目はない
ありえないんです
だからこれ 6つも揃っているか
ひとつ ふたつ 抜けているか ということはありますが
大体 一切の生命にあるのは 眼耳鼻舌身意というその6つなんです
そこを分析して 考えちゃうと
発見できることは 何でしょうかね？
chakkhu自体は 無常でありますね
もう問題ない
眼 自体が
だから それは無我なんです
で 同時に 耳も無我でしょうし
変化するでしょうし
鼻も 変化するでしょうし
舌も もう変化するのは当たり前 わかっていることだから
体も変化することも 体の感覚わかっているでしょうし
心は瞬時に変化するということは またわかっている
わかってなければ 理解してください
で そういうのは変化する
ですから 「この 6つは 無常であって 苦であって 無我であります」と
それで不思議なこと 目に何が触れるかというと
chakkhuには rupa という形が触れるでしょうに
耳には sadda という 音が触れるでしょうに
鼻には gandha という 香りが触れるでしょうに
一応 専門用語は書いておきます
そうやって入る情報は また決まっている
眼には 形しか入りませんし
耳には 音しか入りませんし
仏教用語では これは 眼耳鼻舌身意であって
これは 色声香味触法という 六つですからね
大体 わかっていらっしゃるだろうと思います
耳には sadda しか聞こえない 音しか聞こえない
鼻には 香りしか 認識できません
そういうわけで わからないのは この mana と dhamma なんですね
で manaっていうのは 心自体で
外から情報なくても 我々は頭の中で いろんなことを考えてるでしょ
それは mana と dhamma なんですね
考える時でも 何かについて 考えるでしょ
ですから 考える時は 対象があるんです
昨日食べた ご飯について 今 考えているんだと
瞑想すると思って みんなそれですよ やっているのは
瞑想を置いておいて いろんなことを考えて 妄想したりしている
その時でも いつでも 何かについて 考えているでしょ
何かについてでなければ 考えられませんから
だから その考えるものの対象は dhamma というんですね
dhammaの日本語訳は 法なんですけど
それは ちょっとややこしい言葉で
もう 大雑把でも使えます
「真理」という意味でも使っちゃうし
「法」「教え」という言葉で使っちゃうし
「現象」という言葉でも使うし
そういうふうに 大雑把でも使います
ですから なかなか 説明しにくくなってますけど
でも 意味はわかりやすい 頭で考えるものなんですね
昨日 食べたご飯について 考える
だから昨日食べたご飯が ある必要はないんです
だから あるものを考えられる
「この建物の色は なんでしょうか？」とかね
「これはおそらく黄色い」
「白い いえ 白いじゃないな」
「ちょっと黄色っぽいから クリーム色かな」
「クリーム色とも言いにくい」と
いくらでも考えられるでしょうに
それは 今あるものについて 考えている
そこで 「これを作る前に どんな建物でしたかな？」とか考えられるでしょ
「おそらく これを作って今 20年経っているんだから」
「おそらく 古い日本風な お寺でしたでしょう」とかね
「瓦の屋根でしたでしょう おそらく」とかね
「これ鉄筋コンクリートだから やっぱり屋根はどうか」
「瓦じゃない とにかく」
ですから 現在あるものについても考えられる
もう 今ないものについても考えられる
だから人間に
霊魂のことも 魂のことも
神のことも 考えられる
「だから ある」というわけには ならないでしょ
「私は考えているんだから あるんだ」と
で くだらないことも考えてる
だから くだらないこともあるってわけに ならないでしょうに
だから「私は考える だから私がいる だから魂がある」 というのは
もう いい加減な言葉であって
考えるんだからといって
別に それは事実かないかっていうのは 関係ないんです
人間は 何でも考えられますから
ですから そう分析すると
我々の知識の世界 この理解の世界っていうのは ガタガタと壊れていくはずなんです
人間 困ってる 自分がそう考えてるんだからなんで
「こう考えちゃったら こういう考え方が浮かんだんだよ」と
「だから何ですか？」と
もう 何でも浮かぶんです 頭の中に
ある人は こう言うんですね 神様を信じてる人が
「やっぱり 私は神の概念を壊しちゃったんです とにかく」
「壊しちゃって その代わりにこうやって考えればいいかと」
「あ 私もやっぱり神様はそうじゃなくて こんな感じだなと思ってるんだよ」と
で またおかしいことを言うんですね
「いわゆる Personal Godではないんだ 僕はそんなの ありえない」と
「いわゆる 法則として見たら」
「私もやっぱり 法則自体が 神様だよ と思ってるんだ」と言ったら
「私言うことと全く逆でしょうに」と
「だから神様がいるんだ」と その話した人が そう思っちゃうんですね
自分が考えるんだから いるわけじゃないんです
私たちにはこちらの このお寺 この新しい建物を造る前に
あった建物のことを 考えられるでしょうし
あるいは これ 壊れた時
いつか壊れますから
それから どんな建物を作るだろうと 考えられるでしょうに
だから その通りになりますか？
ならないでしょうし
だから 兎の角がないんだけど 兎の角は考えられます
髪の毛がないんだけど 髪の毛は考えられます
想像もできます 絵も描けます
私は すごい 羊のように いっぱい毛がついてる 亀の絵を描いたとする
それで 羊の毛のように いっぱい毛がついている 亀がいるんですかね？
いる必要 ありますかね?
そういうわけで 人間 一番引っかかっているのは この意識の働きなんです
余計なことを考えて 考えて
「これ ある」と勘違いする
それで お釈迦様の答えが
「chakkhu は 変化するか しないか？」「 変化する」
「見えるものは変化するか しないか？ 」 変化するでしょ 変化しなきゃ見えませんし
これも 耳は変化する 音は変化する
鼻は変化する 香りは変化する
で 舌は変化する それで味は変化するんだから 味わえるんだから
そこで 体は変化する 体に触れるものは 変化する
どっちでも実体がない 心は常に変化する
心で考えるものは むちゃくちゃ変化するんです
「どこに 実体があるんですか？」と
「どこに 毛があるんですか？」と
だから 「我々の感じるすべてのものの中にも ない」ということになるんです
そこで一応 無我ということは 成立するんです
それ そこだけで止まらないで お釈迦様は
「いえ 私は眼で物を見て 知識が生まれたでしょう」と
「知ったでしょう」と
「知ったことは我だ」と言うんです
ジャイナ教は そういうふうに言うんです
「知ることは我ですよ」
知ることは 変化するでしょうに
それで chakkhu viññāna があるんですね
それ全部 viññāna が入るんです
sota viññāna/ ghāna viññāna/ jivhā viññāna/ kāya
viññāna/ mano viññāna と
viññānaだけど これだけ ちょっとつづりが変わります
mano viññāna というわけです
他のものは 大体 同一に書けると思います
そういう chakkhu viññāna
sota viññāna
ghāna viññāna/ jivhā viññāna/ kāya viññāna
viññāna は識
だから chakkhu は眼ですから 「眼識」でしょう おそらく
sota は耳だからね
耳は耳識(じしき) と読むんです
で それはもう魂 永遠じゃないでしょうに
例えば 何か眼で見る
その時の viññāna が音 耳で聞く それはまた違う viññāna だから
で 無常ですから 「それも無常でしょう」ということで
無我ということは成立するんです
で まぁ それ以上は語れないと思います
「それ以上 何かあるか？」と
何かあるかというのは その人が知っていることだからですね
この中に入っちゃうんです
私が まるっきり知らないもの
知り得ないものが あるんだというのも
バカらしいでしょうに
それは 唯識の 阿頼耶識と同じになっちゃうんです
だから 阿頼耶識はないんです
ん？何？
はい mano viññāna は M A N O
そういうわけで なんで いちいち こんな無我のことを お釈迦様がおっしゃったかというと
また あの花の例えに戻って 考えてください
「いいなぁ」と 「ある」と思ったところで 苦しみが生まれる ただそれだけ
「私がいるんだ」と思ったら それこそ不幸だと
「我がある」ということ自体は もうこの世にない
一番恐ろしい 不幸な 暗い概念なんです
それで人間が 一切 苦しみを作る
「魂があるんだから」と思ったら
魂は 救わなくちゃいけないし
なんで 魂を 救ってあげなくちゃいけないんですかね？
魂だから 救ってあげなくてもいいでしょうに
それで 「魂が神様のところに行かなくちゃ」と
で 「神様の機嫌を取らなきゃ そこに行けないんだ」と
それで 神様の機嫌取れない連中は
「どうせ地獄に行くんだから 早く行かせてあげよう」とかね
で 人を殺したりまで したりとかね
想像を絶する苦しみが この世の中で起こるのは
単なる この誤解からなんです
勘違いからなんです
合理的じゃないからなんです
論理的じゃない 合理的じゃない 科学的じゃない
ものは見ない
ですから このセットで 仏教の無我論は 本当は終了します
で それから もうちょっと まぁ 蛇足なんですけど
言い過ぎなことも あります
で 無常という
「無我」という anatta という言葉がありますね
これ anattaという言葉に お釈迦様はもうひとつ
「実体はない」という意味でしょう 「無我ですよ」と
「実体はない」ということは ゼロということなんですね
数学的に考えれば
ゼロには パーリ語で サンスクリット語で śunya というんです
パーリ語だったら suñña
この言葉は 他の言葉にはないんです
中国語でもないんです
だからまあ 育たなかったんです
で 実体はないんだから 「ない」ということを意味するために
suñña という言葉を使うんです
ですから そんなに哲学的な 大変な言葉ではないんです
発展するべき言葉ではないんです
それは ただ「ない」ということを言ってる
śunya  ゼロという概念だけですからね
だから それは あくまでも概念であって
実際に 我々の生きることとは 関係ない言葉なんです
ゼロは
「本当にゼロは存在しますか？」と 例えば 数学的に考えちゃうと
ゼロ自体は 存在しないでしょうに
でも 一応
「我がない」ということで ゼロというんです
ただ 「ここにリンゴは ふたつありますよ」と言ったところで
じゃあ 「１個は」 あの なんとか まぁ
「田中さんが食べた」と
「結局 どれくらいありますか？」 「まだ1個あります」と
「あ もう 1個は 村田さんが食べた」と
「で ありますか？」 「あ ゼロですよ」と
ゼロが あるわけじゃないんです
あのリンゴ  ふたつなければ
そこに 「リンゴ ゼロ」という概念が 成り立たないんですね
そういうわけで ゼロという概念
śunya という概念っていうのは
あの 言って
「無我ですよ」と言って
続けて 言うだけ
だから 「眼耳鼻舌身意は 無我である」と
ゆえに 「空である」と
「色受想行識は 無常ですよ」と
だから「苦ですよ」と
だから「無我ですよ」と
だから「空ですよ」と
そういうわけで お釈迦様の教えでは
もう何のことなく 普通の言葉として 空という概念があるんです
そこで 「すべてのものは 空であることを理解すれば 覚りますよ」と
そういう言葉も 微かにはあるんです
そこで śunya 「何もない」という単なる言葉だから お釈迦様は いろんな言葉を使う
「蜃気楼や」と
「泡だ」と
「現象は 泡のごとくだ」と
「幻や」と
「幻想だ」と
そういうのは一般的な 言う言葉ですね
そこで やがて仏教で śunya という
このもう まぁ どうでもいい
もう まぁ ついでに言った言葉なんですけど
それだけ取って 哲学を作っちゃったんです
「空論」というものが
そこからまた 大変なことになったんです
また あの高度の哲学は 壊れてしまったんです
だから これは余計な 蛇足ですからね
まぁ 聞いても 聞かなくてもいいんですけど
で 仏教はあそこで終わっちゃうんです
どういうことかというと
この犯人が
私は 見つかってますからね
こういう 発展した仏教で
すべての仏教で 考えている
尊敬されている 拝んでいる経典が ひとつあるんです
仏説ではないんです
そちらには「rupa は śunya ですよ」と言うんです
経典は 後で 名前を言います
「rupa は śunya ですよ」と
ぴったし合ってるでしょ お釈迦様の言葉に
rupa は無常でしょうし
だから苦であるし 実体はないでしょうし
だから śunya なんです
確かに お釈迦様がおっしゃったところは あるんです
「Rūpaṃ, bhikkhave, suññaṃ」と
でも その時 お釈迦様は ゼロという数学には入らないように
Suññam idaṃ attena vā attaniyena vā.
「この rupa の中には 実体 自我がないんだから ないと言うんだ śunya というんだ」と
だから 自我 あの
無我ということで
無我 すなわち śunya ということを言っているんです
そこで「rupa は śunya ですよ」という言葉も ぴったし お釈迦様の教えなんですね
そこで もっと威張って
「お釈迦様より もっと進んでいようではないか」と思って
「śunya は rupa ですよ」と言うんです
rupa は 色ですからね
もう 経典わかってると思います
「色は空である」と
次に もっと威張って
「空は すなわち 色ですよ」と言うんです
威張ったんじゃなくて もう
太鼓を手で叩いたら すごい綺麗な音が
「じゃあ 上に乗ってジャンプしよう」 と思ったら バレちゃったと
あれ スティックで叩いたら こんなに綺麗な音が出るんだから
「俺が自分で飛んだら もっと綺麗な音が出るか」と思ったところで
それ バレちゃうんですね
これおかしいんです
色即是空
空即是色ってのはおかしいんです
まるっきり 勘違いなんです
rupa は もう実体がないんだから śunya ですけど
śunya という自体が rupa にならないんです
それ 例を言うとわかります
「犬は動物である」 正しいでしょ
「だから動物は犬である」と
「リンゴは木である」と 「故に木はリンゴですよ」と
こんなこと言う アホがいるんでしょうか と思いますけど
でも 言ってるんです
さらに 進んで言うんです
「rūpān na pṛthak śūnyatā」 と
皆様は これ写経したり 拝んだりするんだけど
原文では わからないでしょ
これはもともとの言葉で こうやって書いてるんです
サンスクリット語で rūpān na pṛthak śūnyatā.
rūpān 色から na pṛthak 異なるものではないと
śūnyatāっていうのは 空は
それはもうその通りです
色というものは空
ですから 別に離れてるの 色自体は空ですよ と
そこでまた 威張っちゃって 逆を言うんですね
śūnyatāyaṇ rūpān na pṛthak rūpaṃ.
そこを「おかしい」と 私が言ってるんです
色は無常だから 空であることはね
「色そのものが空である」ってわかりますけど
「空そのものが色ですよ」と言うと
あまりにも おかしいところなんです
そこで私みたいに この非難しない
批判しないんだから 皆様がよくできてる人々だから
「そこに 何か大事な意味があるんじゃないか」言って
膨大な本があるんです その経典について
全部 間違いです 私から 個人的な意見で言えばね
そこで 何が間違ってるかというと
ここの2行目 間違ったんだから
あ これ 1番目も サンスクリット語で書いておきましょうか
そうするとrūpāṃ śūnyatā
これ 日本語じゃなくて サンスクリット語で覚えていれば かっこいいんです
「あ サンスクリット語でも 知ってるんですか」と
śūnyataiva rūpāṃ
ものすごくここで強調するんです
śūnyatā そのものが rupa であると
すごい厳密に 強調して言うんです
漢文では そんなに厳密に強調しているかどうか ちょっとわかりませんけど 調べてみます
色即是空
で 空即是色
あ その前に 色不異空 空不異色ですね
あまり あの
強調の言葉は 抜けちゃってるんですね 漢字だから
そういう この ちょっと微かなことで 逸れちゃうと
大変なことになるんです
だから これは まぁ 私の説明だから
別に認めても 認めなくても
まぁ どっちでも 全然気にしませんから
まぁ 私は持ってきませんから 何も
で 一応 そういう風になっているんですね
それで問題は この śūnyatā
空は色でしょ
と同時に 受想行を 全部そうなっちゃうでしょ
そうすると 空というものから 現象が現れるという誤解が生まれるんです
空があって 空から色が現れる
これ 書いてるんだから
śūnyataiva rūpāṃ と
不異色と 漢字で言うならば
ですから そこら辺で いろんな人々が いろんな考え方を発達しちゃったんです
だから 空論を 正しく語っているのは
般若経 たくさん膨大な量がありますけど
そちらではなくて 般若論を書いている龍樹さんですね
彼が間違ってないんです
彼にも 欠点 いっぱい 言いたい放題言えば いくらでも僕には 文句は言えますけど
やっぱり そうじゃなくて
一般的に 知識的な 哲学的なレベルで見れば
彼が ぴったし 哲学を語ったんだけど
彼が こんな間違いは 犯していないんです
その「経典」と書いたものは
経典と言った自体でも 嘘を言ってるし
こちらは ちょっと間違ってるんで 間違っていたんだから どうなったかというと
「空という真理の状態から 現象が現れてくるんだ」と
それ よく考えちゃうと
ヒンドゥー教で言ってるのと 同じことなんです
「brahman という実体があって」
「そこから 現象の世界が 変化してくるんだ」と
だから 現象の世界は 無常ですけど
「brahmanは 無常じゃないんだ」と
同じこと こちらでも言えるんです
色は無常ですけど 空は 無常になるはずがないんですから
だから この ちょっと レールがずれたところは そこなんです
そこで さらに進んで この空は 人格化します
人格化して 大日如来というんですね
そちらから「法身」と言うんで
法身仏陀と 法身如来
法身如来というのは 空そのもの
真理そのものなんです
でも そちらから どんどん現象の世界が出てくるんだと
それは仏説でもないし
仏教でもなくなっちゃったんですね
だから すごく残念なことで
ほんのちょっと こちらでもう ズレた コケたところなんです
これは ちょっと子供に聞いたならば 子供 教えてくれるのにね
だからもう お寺の お寺とかね
そういう誰かがね もう
作ったでしょうと 思いますけど
そんな このおかしい論理は きれいさっぱり パーリ経典で まるっきりないんです
例えば
「sankāraは 無常である 空である 無我である」と言うと
逆に じゃあ「涅槃は永遠であって 幸福であって 我ですよ」と
そんな言葉の遊びは してないんです
「無我ですよ」と言う場合は
「すべては無我ですよ」と
涅槃も 抜けてないんです
諸法無我と 言っているんです
だから こういうふうなことで
「A イコール B だから B イコール A ですよ」と
そういう 単純ではダメと
昨日 ちょっと話していた時 友達が言ったのは
掛け算で もっとわかりやすいんだ それはね
A
例えば 「A かける 0 は 0 です」と
「B かける 0 は 0 です」と
「だからといって A イコール B にはならないんだ」と
ならないでしょうに
だから 抽象化したら
事実から離れて
頭の理念だけに 考え方だけに 持ってきたら
そういう問題が 出てきますね
だから 修行を置いておいて 考えるんですね 仏教について
そこで ちょっと 考えすぎちゃったと
そういうことで
一応 空という実体が 成り立つようになってしまった
ですから「空というのは 何もないことではないんだ」と 私にも 教えてくれちゃったんです
従順と言ってみれば もうそんなことではないんだけど
その ない あるという 問題じゃないんですけどね
「あ そうですか」と笑っていたんですけど
なぜならば 僕は サンスクリット語で 読んでいるんだからね
一応 ほんのわずかなところが ズレたんだからね
そういうところで 考え方が 変わってしまったんです
ですから 結局 これ 私だけの個人的な意見なんですけど
そこで 間違ったところで
後で 宗派 部派に分かれて 仏教が変化していったところで
また ヒンドゥー的な考え方に 戻ってしまったと
お釈迦様 嫌だと 出た家に また戻ったと
偉そうに家を出て 仏教という世界が
「やっぱり戻ります」ということで ものすごい負け犬というかね
お釈迦様は 戻らなかったんですけどね
そういうのは どうせ人間が考えたりするとね
そういう 間違いというかね
そういうことっていうのは ありえますけどね
また 次から次へと これ研究していっちゃうと
もっともっと もう出ますけどね
でも 今日は そういう 空論に語る時ではないんだから
「空は 初期仏教でもある言葉だよ」というだけ 理解してください
空という概念というのは
これは 大乗仏教だけの概念ということではなくて
私たちにとっても いとも簡単に 使っていた言葉なんですね
これ 数学 間違ったんだからね
そこで ちょっと おかしいんだと
ですから 解脱を得ても また戻れるんですね
戻るも 戻るんです
空論を 持ってきたら
だから 空という絶対的な真理に行っても
その絶対真理から また現象が現れるでしょうし
そこで 菩薩の概念は いとも簡単に 成り立つんです
菩薩は 本当は 如来なんですけど
化け物になって 観音とか いろいろ変化して 人を救うために また来るんだと
でも 救われた人は また向こうに行ったら また戻るんだから
結局 輪廻なんですね
最終解脱とか ノン解脱の世界ではなくなっちゃう
だから そういうのは ほとんど別に
実際の状況はどうであろうが
哲学的に分析すると
そういう風に なることは なるんですね
ですから なんかちょっと 初期仏教と 今ある大乗仏教
なんか随分違うところが見えるのは そういうところでなんですね
うん  そういうことで
「無我を理解することは 解脱である」という言葉で
話を 終了させていただきます
どうも ありがとうございました